what did I just watch the lovely bones
yeah that wasn't so lovely now if you've
seen the trailer you've seen the movie
and I really mean that the trailer left
nothing to be discovered so the movie
follows a girl who's stuck in between
worlds after her murder yeah apparently
after you get murdered you're stuck in a
world that's kind of like what dreams
may come had a kid with Mario Galaxy and
crossbred with the yellow submarine and
it wouldn't be so bad
scratch that it would be better if a
world comprised some entirely special
effects had good special effects the
fact is an afterlife that's comprised of
special effects that make x-men origins
Wolverine look like avatar yeah that's
nothing in between that is hell now what
I did like about this movie is that it
did awkward and intense very well most
scenes involving this guy were the most
intense white-knuckle anxiety scenes
I've seen since the Joker had a knife in
gambles mouth yeah very intense yeah
kids don't take lollipops from a guy who
looks like Milton from office spaces
brother nine out of ten scenes this guy
was in was a bad as settling as the
Bjork stalker video other than excelling
at that the movie fails on everything
else
namely to little things like character
and structure I mean the performances
were okay but Marky Mark still breathes
everywhere he speaks it's okay don't say
that no it's okay we're gonna find her I
know what to do we call it the police
that's gonna be good okay Suzy salmon
and milton number two best actors in the
movie hands down the movie was just
constructed weird
it had the Peter Jackson style
cinematography but honestly speaking
having Peter Jackson style
cinematography in this movie is like
calling in the National Guard to get a
cat out of a tree just seems like a bit
much in the end they'll sum it up to you
like this this movie is like chasing bad
mushrooms with Dale beer it's flat as
hell and all the pretty colors you see
don't take away from the fact that
you're left with a really shitty taste
in your mouth however not that I condone
drugs but if you happen to be tripping
balls like right now then go watch The
Lovely Bones like this second yeah at
least it'll be memorable now what would
it redeem this movie Dexter Morgan
wrapping this guy up in cellophane and
feeding his Dark Passenger and if you
don't know what that means for the love
of God watch Dexter and if you like what
you've seen here click on the link in
the sidebar to subscribe to see more or
click the button yeah I like the button
I'm keeping the button what's the button
here
[Music]